okay everyone so welcome to this uh
Hands-On Workshop about a few short
learning in production
um I'm really excited that uh you're
joining us from all over the world and
this is work that um was done in
collaboration with researchers at
hugging face at Intel and the ukp lab in
Germany
and my name is Lewis I'm an engineer in
the open source team at hugging face and
I'll just briefly introduce my
co-authors I have um here with me Moshi
and Aaron from Intel Moshi would you
like to tell us a little bit about
we're doing research active research and
efficiency in NLP
hi I'm Oren I'm from the NLP team at
emergent AI Lab at interlabs
uh
have a lot of experience in efficient
NLP
awesome thanks a lot machine Aaron so
for everyone joining us um on YouTube uh
just post your comments or questions and
we'll answer them either as they arise
or at the end
um but um in the meantime
um if you want to uh kind of get a sense
of what this is about we have a few
materials and we'll be posting the
slides um online later today
um but basically this this is work that
comes from a paper around using sentence
Transformers for fuchsia text
classification in a very kind of
efficient way
and this is called a set fit and there's
a repository
um where you can visit
um in a blog post but today we're going
to be focusing on a kind of advanced
technique of using this so like sort of
you know what do you do when even with
you know a good model you want to deploy
this um in some efficient way
so the kind of plan of attack for for
the workshop today is um just to give a
bit of an explanation about what set fit
is how it works and also to then talk
about some of the sort of Advanced
Techniques we looked at in our paper on
compressing these models
um so that you can essentially deploy
them on on very you know small devices
or you know at scale if you need to
we'll also do a Hands-On demo showing
you how we can do this in code on colab
and as I said before if you have any
questions just Chuck them in the chat
and we'll answer them on the fly or as
we go
okay so let's Dive In
so
um just for those who maybe are new to
this field of future learning
um there's like many different kind of
definitions of future learning in in the
literature but I think the most famous
One
um really comes from the gpt3 paper by
openai
and in that case or in that paper what
they were
um sort of showing
is that when you do language modeling so
when you do pre-training at scale a
large part of the Corpus includes
instructions where you might for example
see something like translate English to
French some of these examples here and
then what you can do is you can get the
model to kind of complete
um those examples and then it kind of
implicitly learns how to do for example
translation even though it's never
explicitly trained on a translation task
and the reason it's called fuchsia is
because you provide a few of these kind
of examples to sort of prime the model
at inference time
um and in the case of like large
language models like gpt3 this is
typically called in context learning
because you're basically doing this at
inference time based on the context
and the in the original gpt3 paper they
showed that if you look at the kind of
accuracy over many different benchmarks
in NLP you see this kind of you know
gradual Trend as you scale the number of
parameters in in the model and so for
example the the line here that we're
interested in is this orange line for
the fuchsia
and so you can see that basically you
know when the language model is at the
scale of like say like I don't know Bert
or a bit larger your performance or your
average accuracy is around 35
but as you scale up to like the 175
billion parameters of gpd3 you you
roughly you know
um kind of double that or let's say one
and a half times that average accuracy
so this kind of suggests like a
promising uh way of thinking about how
do we deal with this common issue in in
machine learning as a whole where you
don't have many labeled examples and
maybe you would like to be able to just
kind of provide the model at inference
time these examples and then it just
automatically is able to generate the
completion whether it's a you know
translation or a class if you're doing
classification
so this is exciting and you know has led
to a whole you know slew of different um
you know extensions to this idea and
different ways of prompting the model
and so on
um but it does have kind of two like
sort of drawbacks so the first one is
that the the performance
um of you know these few shot
um approaches is very sensitive to the
way that you prompt uh the model so in
the example here you can see it's like
translate English to French and then
there's a few examples of English to
French
um but it turns out if we kind of maybe
you know picked the wrong examples or
you know different examples then we
could get quite different performance
um in these completions
and so this has led to like a kind of
sort of own field and what's called
prompt engineering where people devote a
lot of time thinking about okay what are
the ways we can kind of prompt these
language models to boost the performance
and you may have seen on Twitter or
other places where people do funny
things like say you know think step by
step and then simply telling the model
to think step by step actually gets it
to sort of break down the logic and how
it's doing its completions
so that's the sort of first drawback is
this idea of having to always manually
prompt the model and come up with clever
prompts and the second one is that you
know you can see in this plot that the
performance really starts to take off at
this like 175 billion parameter scale
and these kind of models are not the
kind of models that you just have you
know lying under your bed and you just
Chuck them on your laptop these are
really really big things which need you
know distributed distributed uh
infrastructure for for inference
so although very promising there are
these kind of two two main drawbacks and
to sort of deal with this there have
been a variety of techniques in the
literature
um to sort of find ways that we can sort
of maybe train smaller models
um in a more efficient way
and the current state of the art
um is a technique called tfue
um and this technique uses a kind of
clever idea where if we take a large
language model maybe we don't need to
update all of the parameters when we're
kind of doing fine-tuning on our small
labeled examples maybe what we can do is
we can insert inside the network what
are called adapter layers and these
adapter layers are basically just like
small kind of like you know feed forward
Networks and basically then what we can
do is we can just do fine tuning on the
small labeled examples with these
adapter layers and this is a much more
efficient way of kind of adjusting the
sort of original model whether it's gpd3
or something else
um to the sort of task at hand
and so tfue has this very nice property
that it can do multitask training so
just using these adapter layers you can
basically train across you know many
different tasks whether it's you know
classification tasks token
classification translation and so on
and what they show in this paper
um is that by using this kind of
efficient adapter layers they're able to
get not only like very good accuracy
compared to sort of the original gpt3
models so you can see on this plot that
the sort of accuracy on the on the
y-axis is better for tfue but the actual
number of flops that are needed for
inference and training is significant
less so you can see here that if I want
to just do an inference using like the
gbt3 large I'm going to need around 10
to the 15 flops for my inference my Ford
pass
and TPU is significantly more efficient
it's like three orders of magnitude more
efficient than gpt3
so this is currently the state of the
art for kind of few short learning with
um reasonably large language models
um but again it has a kind of um sort of
issue that um I mentioned before that by
being a kind of language model technique
it requires prompt engineering so you
still have to write your own prompts and
this you know in our experience is also
kind of a little bit like labeling your
own data so you end up kind of doing a
bit of double the work
and the other thing is that TPU um
despite being you know much more
efficient than gpd3
um it still requires a relatively large
um a large model so the it's based on
something called the t0 model which is a
model that came out from the big science
collaboration and this model is 11
billion parameters which roughly
translates into around 11 gigs of disk
space
so again deploying this model is not
sort of like a super easy thing it's
much easier than gpd3 but it is still
nevertheless something that requires you
know some kind of specialized Hardware
okay so I've got let's check if there's
any questions
um so there's a question here from Amit
who says does tfu approach all the
lights issue it only helps with training
and future learning yeah so that's a
great question uh for a moment so in the
tfue paper they show that um both the
training and inference they are
significantly more efficient than models
like g53 and that's just primarily due
to the fact that they're using a smaller
model so they're using a t0 model which
is around you know 10 times smaller than
253 and for the training side it's much
more efficient just due to the nature of
you know only having to essentially
train a small number of the parameters
of the total model so great question
foreign
Okay so
I've sort of talked a little bit about
sort of original gp3 approach and um a
more recent extension called tfue
um so the kind of question that you know
we asked ourselves uh in this
collaboration is you know the all these
advances are really exciting if you're
like a researcher and you're you know
interested in sort of generative models
but a very large part of like the
day-to-day work as a data scientist in
NLP is around kind of natural language
understandings so things like you know
extracting embeddings or you know doing
text classification these are kind of
very common tasks in industry and uh the
kind of question that we were interested
in is you know can we do better than
these kind of other other methods
and it turns out the answer is yes it
involves a kind of very simple idea
which Moshe came up with
and we call this technique set fit which
is a shorthand for sentence Transformer
fine-tuning
and the basic idea here is that sentence
Transformers if you've never heard of
them they're essentially
extension or an adaptation of the kind
of bird type models that you're familiar
with
but they're essentially trained
um in in a way where essentially you can
do kind of like a Siamese Network which
allows you to learn very very good
representations
um of text and so sentence Transformers
kind of by themselves tend to produce
much better embeddings than you know
vanilla models like burp
and the idea behind set fit is okay
we've got these very good
representations from these models can we
adapt them essentially fine-tune them on
a small number of labeled examples and
then use that kind of now fine-tuned
sentence Transformer to basically feed
representations into a classifier or a
classification head and then generate
the final predictions
so as you can see in this diagram there
are these two kind of stages of training
the first one is to adapt or fine-tune
the sentence Transformer on a small
number of examples and the way we do
that uses a technique called contrastive
learning where you essentially sample
um you know for example examples that
might be positive so you know this movie
is great and examples that are negative
which is like this movie sucks and then
contrastive learning will essentially
adapt the sentence Transformer to kind
of cluster the embeddings further apart
from each other so that then when we do
classification in the second stage we've
got a very good decision boundary to
work with
and as I mentioned at the start this is
something that works very well for text
classification it also works very well
for multilingual applications because
there are a large number of multilingual
sentence Transformers that work well and
we're currently having a look at whether
we can extend this to Total
classification which is another very
common task in industry
so as I was saying before like the kind
of idea of like you know what this
contrastive learning step is doing if we
sort of visualize it the idea could be
that you know at the start we might have
um some some text which is kind of
categorized in terms of you know maybe
business sport politics entertainment
Tech these could be like news articles
and although the diagram here is a
universal sentence encoder we can just
imagine this is you know sort of like
our starting point with that sentence
Transformer and so we've got some sort
of you know nice clusters but we've got
some overlap in various places
and then the idea is that once we do
this contrasted learning
um then we get essentially much tighter
clustering which then allows us to
create very clean decision boundaries
when we do classification on top of them
and so that's the kind of main idea
behind set fit is essentially around
generating good representations that
then we can use to to build classifiers
and just to give you a high level
summary
um it works typically quite well with
around eight to ten labels labeled
examples per class
in some examples or some data sets that
we studied you can actually match the
full fine tuning on thousands of
examples of like Bert or Roberta I'm
just using eight labeled examples
and it also works for any type of
sentence Transformer on the Hub so this
is like a kind of big plus where you can
just mix and match you know pick a
different checkpoint to see what you get
and you also don't have to write
anything any prompts yourself this is
just using kind of standard like
representation learning
where your inputs are just your text and
then the contrast of learning takes care
of you know building these good
representations
and as we'll see um rather soon
um it's very efficient you can run this
on one GPU in a matter of seconds
um and on a standard CPU on a matter of
minutes so this this really is a very
big kind of contrast to say gpt3 or even
T few where you typically need at least
you know one 80 gigabyte a100 to start
with or you know multiple gigabyte I'm
sorry multiple a100s if you want to run
you know something like you know gpt3 or
bloom
so this is really kind of helping us get
closer to you know making future
learning accessible
um sort of to the average practitioner
and to give you a kind of measure of um
you know where it stands relative to
sort of these like fancier techniques
here's a plot from raft which is a
benchmark that's commonly used for
assessing the sort of performance of
future learning methods
and what you can see here are a variety
of language models so we have things for
example like Bloom we have gpt3 we have
these instruct models from open AI which
are kind of advanced fine-tuned versions
of gpt3 there's models from cohere so
kind of like the sort of Who's Who of
either language models and you can see
that you know the instruct models
typically do do best
um and they have you know parameters in
the scales of like 100 billion
um whereas you know set fit or set fit
using um a sort of Roberta model
um as a backbone
um typically gets kind of comparable
performance but as you know two and a
half orders of magnitude smaller so this
is kind of this efficiency component
um that I was talking about at the start
so let me just take a couple of
questions
um from the audience there's one here
from amrap who's asking does a set fit
work well for multi-label text
classification with open labels
um and can different levels exist in new
data that's a that's a really good
question so um in our paper we didn't do
any uh benchmarking in in the
multi-label case
um but one of my colleagues at hogi face
um he extended this for the multi-level
setting and found that you know in
general you can get good performance
um provided that you don't have a huge
amount of imbalance in the multi-label
context so my sort of General answer is
like try it out because you can run it
in seconds
but yeah as a general rule it does work
but it depends on the data
um okay let me see if there's any sort
of last questions
okay
oh yeah okay and then maybe a common
question here which is something like
just to explain is um you know what does
per class mean
um so basically when we um are talking
about say uh you know few shot uh
learning
um often we say okay how many labeled
examples do I have
um in my training Set uh per class so if
I have for example like a sentiment
analysis data set I've got two classes
and the kind of few shot regime of that
might be for example having you know
eight examples that are positive and
eight examples that are negative and
we're going to see this kind of
terminology per class
um you know appear more and more as we
go through the
um through the session
good question
and uh last question here I'll take
before we move on is does it work for
named entity recognition so at the
moment
um we haven't kind of cracked that task
um but we're looking into it and um if
we do then you know you'll find out soon
enough
and yes I'll be I'll be sharing the
slides later on so um I'll put them in
the YouTube video which is actually
being recorded So once this goes um to
YouTube I'll add this I'll add the
slides in the description and I'll also
show you later when we do the Hands-On
session where you can get the slides as
well
okay so let's go
um so everything
um you know I talked about so far was
kind of just set fit using
um typically a model that is roughly the
size of you know Bert so so this is
something that you know a few hundred
megabytes of disk space
um and the question that you know you
usually ask yourself when you say okay
I've got something that works is you
know now I want to deploy this uh to
production and maybe I have some
constraints that I need to take into
take into account so the kind of obvious
ones that come up is like maybe you want
to save money
so if you're able to kind of make your
models smaller you may find that you can
use you know one instance instead of 10.
in the case of models like set fit you
might be able to for example run them on
very small like Edge devices
if you can compress them
the other one is that you know by kind
of shrinking your models you might be
able to then increase your throughput
because you can now you know essentially
fit you know more queries or pass more
queries per second because your latency
goes up so it goes down and the other
one is um you know there are sometimes
like some use cases for example if
you're building you know chat Bots or
things that have like low latency
requirements
um which you know may be unlocked if you
can show that you know you can reduce
the latency from let's say 20
milliseconds to say one
so these are kind of like the three
things that um you know people usually
keep in mind when you know going to
production and asking you know should we
optimize these models
and there are these like three main
techniques that are sort of commonly
used and motion iron uh kind of like
World experts in all of these
and the the ones that we're going to
look at today
um is a technique called knowledge
distillation
um and a technique called weight
quantization
and there's a lot of interesting work
that's actually been done by Intel
around this idea called weight pruning
or how do you kind of sparsify
um the weights in your network but we
won't have time to go into that today so
we'll just have a look at these other
two techniques which are very common and
as we'll see they can bring significant
gains in your latency
so I'll start by just giving a high
level description of knowledge
distillation before handing over to Oren
and he can explain the sort of how we
did it for SEPTA specifically but the
basic idea of knowledge distillation is
you have two models and you have a model
that's called the teacher and this this
model is typically a large model or it's
a model that gets very good accuracy
um on on the test set that you're
interested in um you know comparing
and this teacher model is typically a
thing that you know is too big to put
into production
so what you can do is you can take a
smaller model which is called a student
and then you can use essentially
information from the teacher to kind of
guide the training of the student so
that it basically mimics the the
predictions of this teacher which is you
know gets good accuracy but it is also
able to kind of you know benefit from
what's been learned there together with
the labels of the original data to get a
student that would be basically better
performant than if you just trained it
by itself
and the way this works in this diagram
is we've got some example like the tacos
were okay the label here could be meh
and we feed both of these
um into the teacher and the student
model
and you know when we compute the loss
the thing that we typically optimize
during training for classification tasks
this is usually like the cross entropy
so that's you know one thing that we
derive directly from from the label
but the other thing that we can do is we
can actually compare the distribution of
the logits coming from the teacher and
from the student
and so what you can see in this diagram
is that you know the teacher and the
student will typically have different
distributions especially at the start
when the student is basically just you
know randomly initialized
but we can compute something called the
KL Divergence which is essentially a
measure of like how different these two
distributions are
and by kind of treating this as a loss
then we can optimize during training to
essentially guide the student to mimic
much closer
the distribution of the teacher and at
the end of the day we end up with
something that typically then has
similar performance to the teacher but
is also much smaller therefore can run
faster
so this is like the kind of high level
view of knowledge distillation
um in the context of you know standard
classification
um but in set fit we took a slightly
different approach and I'll now let
Aaron um explain how that worked
great thank you Lewis
um so Lewis showed a generic
distillation setup and now we're going
to see the specific distillation setup
that we used for a set fit and the basic
idea is as into this in the generic
distribution setup is to train a small
set with student model to mimic the
larger set fit teacher model
in the set feed paper we use the version
of set fit which is based on the empty
net sentence Transformer this is a model
roughly of the size of bird base 110
million parameters
and this model produced a very good
results across all of our data sets
so in the distillation setup we decided
to use this model as a teacher model
and for the students model we used a
paraphrase mini LM L3 sentence
Transformer which is a sentence
Transformer that contains only 15
million parameters so that's seven times
smaller than the teacher model
and this model is of course much more
efficient and much more practical to
deploy
so the first step of the distillation
setup is to train the teacher and in the
paper we trained the teacher using 16
label samples per class across all of
our data sets
and the next step if you look at the
block diagram here is uh to use
unlabeled data and to use the teacher
model to encode the data so just to make
it clear and the training step of the
teacher we use the those 16 labeled
samples per class this is the label data
but in the distillation setup we only
use unlabeled data we don't we don't use
labeled data at all
so we run this unlabeled data through
the teacher model
the sentence Transformer of the teacher
model we encode the data and produce
embedding so now we have embedding
paired sentence and once we have it
we're producing the cosine similarity
Matrix that you see here and this is
essentially a matrix that represents uh
the cosine similarity between the
different pairs in the unlabeled data
so that would be the first step
and the next step if you can click Lewis
oh sorry go back
it didn't work
maybe else to slide yeah
so okay so maybe we can just explain it
in words okay okay I explain it okay and
the next step will be uh to just uh
generate or just uh sample randomly
sample pairs from this uh this unlabeled
data
and then use those unlabeled use those
randomly sample the pairs in order to
train the smaller uh set fit model it's
the sentence Transformer of the smaller
set fit model
and we're training the student by
minimizing the loss between its cosine
similarity the cosine similarity in the
output of the smaller the student
sentence Transformer and the cosine
similarity score produced
by encoding the uh the unlabeled data
using the teacher this this uh causing
similarity here that we see in the
cosine similarity Matrix
so that's essentially the the main step
of uh of training the uh the student
sentence Transformer and finally the
last step will be to train the
classification head of the student
by using the embeddings produced by the
student and the logits produced by the
teacher
yeah go ahead
thank you
and now let's see some results uh here
in this table we see a comparison
between set feet mpinet which is our
teacher model with 110 million
parameters
and the set fit student which is uh
based on Mini LM which is only 15
million parameters
and in this test we use 16 labeled
samples per class for training the
teacher and for the distillation
we added all of the available training
data
and use it as unlabeled data we just
remove the labels from the training data
and used it as unlabeled data
and if you look at the score here on the
right the rightmost column this
represents the average score across all
of our five test data sets in the paper
and we can see that the set fit student
with which is seven times smaller
just falls short of the set free teacher
with only two points and if we convert
it to compare the TV with 3 billion
parameters we see that the difference is
only three points
so the bottom line here is that set fit
can be even more efficient when using
smaller models in distillation setups
great thanks there's actually a question
which is quite relevant here
um so the first one is from Alexander
which is you know what is the benefit of
using this unlabeled data if we kind of
need these like you know 16 labeled
examples in the first place for the
teacher
so maybe what's the intuition behind you
know using unlabeled data for the
distillation step
yeah and of course if we were using this
just the label data directly on the set
feed student the results will be much
lower and you will see it later and the
intuition is that the set feed student
mimics the output of the set feed
teacher and the set feed teacher is much
much much larger and the accuracy is
much much better
and the set fit teacher actually
produces you can look at it as pseudo
labels for the uh for the set fit
student
and and we did see that uh when we use
more and more unlabeled data usually the
results are improving
great and there's another question which
I think is kind of relevant which is uh
you know as a concept as knowledge
distillation work if the sort of
architecture of the teacher and the
student are like significantly different
um I I have like my own kind of
experience with this but I'm curious uh
you know what's your experience
actually I can also comment uh we in the
past we try with via SDM and actually
it's work great so yeah I also recommend
to try with by the stem and smaller
model
um and there is some some nice blobs
that I can share with you in the
comments later how to do it with by the
stem or right
right so you mean we had a Transformer
teacher model and then we had a totally
different student model like pile SDM
which is
very different and it worked
yeah the only thing I've experienced
before is if you are just using
Transformer models like you know Roberto
and Roberto and so on if you try to like
distill like I don't know Roberta into
like but you get like a kind of mismatch
sometimes in in the performance like
it's like worse than sort of your
intuition expects and you know the kind
of usual explanation for this is that
maybe like the representation spaces are
like so different for these two models
that you know when you do the
distillation it doesn't quite transfer
um but yeah I definitely agree that on
the lstm side this does work quite
nicely yeah I can also add that's
probably very much data set dependent so
or simpler more semantic lexical data
set is which probably will work great
but if you have a very challenging data
set you need a larger model so you might
be able to do it with wireless thing you
have to get a larger motor or
Transformer
so it's very much dependent on the data
set and discuss
in general exactly and I'll take one
more question before we move on
um so why don't you use the predictions
of the teacher model for training so I
guess the question is you know why pick
cosine similarity
um when you know the conventional
knowledge distillation setup is to like
kind of look at the logits like I showed
before and then compute the sort of
difference in the in the Logics itself
right because we thought that set fit
you know the main the body of the set
with this sentence Transformer and the
uh the objective there is cosine
similarity so that's why we wanted to
mimic the question similarity of the
teacher but in the second step we do
have a classification head in set fit so
in the sadness in the second step we do
use the predictions of the teacher to
train the uh the classification head
of the student model yeah the second
step
so we use both
great so then
let's now
um
take a look Okay so we've looked at like
knowledge installation and we're going
to show you some code where you'll see
this in action
um but um the last thing we want to sort
of mention before diving into some some
examples is this other very common
technique
um that's used for optimizing models
called quantization
um and the kind of basic idea of
quantization is that you know typically
the parameters of transform models
whether the sentence Transformers or
else
um are typically like 32-bit floating
point so this means that you know every
activation and every weight basically
has like a kind of range of values on 32
bits
um but it turns out that if you look at
the distributions in the layers of your
network they often don't take these
extremely large ranges and so you don't
actually need that much kind of
information to kind of capture the
Salient features of the model so if you
could find a way to essentially map the
range of values from 32-bit to some
smaller range this would effectively use
less memory and it will also increase
your speed because when you do matrix
multiplication with smaller amount of
precision you get you know some speed up
if you're you know CPU instruction set
supports it
so what you can see in this example here
is this is kind of like um the sort of
distribution of of parameters in one of
the layers of Bert and you can imagine
you know you can see here that the range
is only between you know minus like 0.2
and 0.2 so what we could do is we could
kind of convert all of these values into
8-bit integer
and this has the kind of effect of like
discretizing uh the distribution uh
somewhat and the way this works in
practice is you sort of take your
original real value your 32-bit you
divide it by some scale factor and then
you have to add this other constant
called a zero point which just ensures
that you know the 0 and 32-bit aligns
with the zero of 8-bit
and so this is you can just think of
this as just a way of just you know
mapping all the numbers in your model
um into some smaller
um kind of precision
and as you may expect there will
typically be you know some loss in
accuracy that's kind of like the general
trade-off that you you face so as you go
to lower and lower Precision you
typically face a bigger penalty um in
accuracy
and there are many different Frameworks
for um
essentially doing this quantization
technique so you may have heard of
things like Onyx runtime even pytorch
natively supports quantization but what
we're going to use today is is a pretty
nifty open source Library
um from Intel called the Intel neural
compressor
and this essentially is an open source
library that kind of encapsulates
um you know many of these sort of other
Frameworks so it's kind of compatible
with Onyx runtime it's compatible with
Optimum which is a library we have at
hugging face for
um optimizing Transformers
and it has like some nice features
around quantization where it basically
has like a tuner that tries to figure
out kind of what are the optimal parts
of the model to quantize so that you
minimize the amount of you know
degradation from quantization
and this is uh quite different from say
Pi torch where natively pytorch would
just kind of you know quantize whatever
layers that you specify and you sort of
lose a little bit of that kind of you
know finding the optimal amount um
parameters to quantize
so we'll see this in action shortly and
the kind of basic architecture of this
library is that you're trying to build a
bridge between like like deep learning
models and you know hardware backends
and so you can imagine that like you
know for most people the transition is
like you know trainer model and Pie
torch or tensorflow and then deploy it
somehow
um and depending on you know the
hardware you might find that you know
just using native pytorch isn't going to
cut it so you typically convert pytorch
into some other format whether it's on
an X or you know torch script or
something and then that's the thing that
you then Deploy on a specific back end
and the sort of interneural compressor
provides this kind of bridge
um starting from a model and then having
support for different kinds of
Frameworks so whether it's just like
hanging face Transformers or just
pytorch models and then inside you have
all these different say compression
algorithms and tuning strategies to do
that conversion of like taking a model
and making it you know faster and then
at the very end you can have like a
target for a sort of you know dedicated
back end so you know are you running on
a specific type of CPU are you running
on gpus and so on
so we'll see this in action
um very shortly but let me just see if
there's any kind of last questions
before we jump into the code
so let's see
yeah so here's here's something that
we'll see shortly which is um you know
I've quantized a model
um now can I do distillation to make it
faster and smaller so
um I think the answer is maybe yes but
doing it the other way around is
probably better so first distill the
model so you're doing everything in you
know full precision and generally
training models in full Precision is is
more stable and then you can quantize it
to get that final boost
and we'll see that uh you know very
shortly
okay so let's uh jump into some code you
know showing slides is nice but let's
see it in action so
um basically if you go to hugging face
on GitHub we have a repository called um
workshops
and in this repository
um you can go to the few short learning
in production folder
and here we have a link to the slides so
if you click on this this will take you
to the slides that we just showed today
um and you can also click on this
notebook here called set feed
optimization
and this has a little button for opening
collab which you can click on and then
this will now
um you know spin up the the notebook and
collab and you can then switch you know
your GPU sorry your runtime to GPU and
then you can now run everything as you
go
I'm going to run this on my own GPU just
because it's a little bit more stable
than color but I'm not sure I trust
collab to always do everything I want
um but basically what this notebook is
going to show you is how to use these
two techniques we just covered so we're
going to first use knowledge
installation
um with the method Oren described to
shrink
um the sort of teacher model into a
small student and then we're going to
take that distilled model and we're
going to then quantize it using the
Intel neural compressor to sort of
squeeze out the last bit of performance
and just to give you kind of rough rules
of thumb like it depends a lot on the on
the model and stuff but typically you
know you'll see a two to four x
reduction in size from knowledge
distillation and then another kind of
additional 2x compression at the
quantization step and these numbers kind
of vary you know depending on the model
and stuff but that kind of gives you a
rough idea that if you combine these two
methods you're able to kind of compress
a model you know maybe by as much as 10x
which again you know translates
potentially into you know a 10x
reduction in your kind of diploma costs
so there's a few things you just have to
install the dependencies and I'm just
going to turn off a bunch of warnings
from from Transformers
um so let's talk about you know how are
we going to compare the models that we
train
so the sort of most common thing that um
you'll experience when you want to
deploy models into production
environments is there's kind of this
sort of trade-off between the
performance of the model so kind of like
you know what is it accuracy or you know
what are the metrics that are important
for solving the task at hand
uh the other one is the latency so kind
of like how fast can your model deliver
predictions and then the third one is is
like memory so kind of like essentially
how much RAM or GPU memory does the
model take
um and that can be important
um if you're dealing with you know very
like small devices
um you know maybe you want to run the
model actually you know in your phone or
if you want to run you know on very
small instances
um you know in a data center so you can
you know save costs this way
so each one of these things is often in
a little bit of tension because you know
if you try to optimize exclusively for
latency you may get a hit on on the
performance of the model and vice versa
if you just optimize for model
performance you may end up having you
know large models and so figuring out
what is the best combination
um depends on your use case
but today we're just going to look at
kind of the relative gains that can be
had by by sort of looking at these three
dimensions
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to create a performance
benchmark
which will allow us to feed in a set fit
model a data set and a kind of name for
you know the the type of model that
we're dealing with
and this function or this class is going
to compute
um the three the three things we talked
about so it's going to compute accuracy
it's going to compute the size of the
model and then it's going to also do a
timing of the model so that we can
measure the latency
and I won't go into all the details here
they're maybe not so interesting but
basically we just generate predictions
from the model and compute metrics using
the evaluate library from hugging phase
and then to compute the size we just
look at the sort of State dictionary of
the pytorch model
and then for the latency calculation we
just basically Loop over
um a hundred examples of some query and
then we just compute the average
latencies and the distribution from that
so if I run this cell
we've now got something that we can use
to compare models
and what we will be focusing on today is
a data set called EG news
so the AG news data set is a fairly
popular one in NLP and you can see here
it's essentially a data set of like news
headlines or you know Snippets of news
articles which are then categorized into
four different classes I think it's like
business sport
politics or world and then you know
technology
so you can see here in this example it's
like Wall Street bears blah blah blah
something short sellers Wall Street
something so you know this is like
something about maybe business
um and then if we look at another
example down below I think we have one
here this is like more like a tech one
it's like you know AOL to sell PCS to
minorities and seniors blah blah so you
get a sense that like you know we've got
text that has quite different kind of
categories and the kind of question is
you know can we train a classifier
um on this data set but only using a
very very small amount of the labeled
examples
and
just check if there's any issues
um
I think this data set is quite large
it's like over 1 million news articles
and what we're going to try and do is
see if we can
um you know just use maybe eight
articles per per each one of these four
classes to train a classifier
so
we've loaded our data set
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a bunch of different
training sets for the different things
that we want to do
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to create
a split I'm going to split my kind of
full training set into two pieces the
first piece is going to be used for
creating these like few examples a few
labeled examples that we'll use for
training the teacher
and the second part I'm going to use as
the sort of unlabeled data that we would
use you know for training the student
with knowledge distillation
and you can kind of imagine that in like
many practical use cases
um you will have like maybe a few
labeled examples but you might have a
pretty large number of unlabeled
examples and this is kind of true if
you're in like domains where domain
expertise is kind of really important
right you can imagine if I'm doing like
law contract
um you know classification it's
expensive to get lawyers to you know
manually go through and annotate my data
um so I might have a few examples at the
start of my project and then I might
have a whole you know stack of contracts
that haven't been labeled and so this is
what we're kind of simulating here is a
scenario where you start off you know
having just maybe 10 examples labeled
and then you want to see if you can use
that to squeeze more performance on the
unlevel data
so this um the cell just basically
samples
um these kind of a few short examples
from the from the training set and we
can have a look here
um we've now got 32 examples for
training the teacher and the reason it's
32 is we're going to basically take
eight examples per class we've got four
classes and if I remember my math 8x4 is
32.
and similarly if we look at the um the
student we've now got these 1000
examples and we're not going to use the
label of this at all we're just going to
use the raw text
for distillation and then for the test
data set
um here we're using the full thing which
is you know relatively large but this is
just as a way of measuring you know how
well the models are if we had less it
would also be fine
so the way this works when you train a
standard set fit model is first we're
going to load a pre-trained sentence
Transformer from The Hub
and this is essentially going to
download the weights from The Hub and
then it's going to attach a
classification head on top of this model
which is the thing that we need to train
in the second stage of set fit
and then we're going to feed that model
into a trainer we provide just the model
and the the training set and there's a
bunch of default parameters that we're
using which basically tend to work out
of the box we're going to train the
model and then we're going to feed the
resulting model into this performance
Benchmark class to compute some metrics
so I'm just going to run this now and
this should give us a sense of how fast
step it is so you can see here it's
taking maybe 15 seconds
um I'm running just on on one GPU
um and this is you know essentially
doing that contrastive learning step uh
we spoke about on these you know 32
labeled examples
um to essentially
kind of tune the sensor Transformer and
then we just do a kind of logistic
regression on the top of that
and what you can see is that the model
size is around 400 megabytes it gets an
accuracy of around 82 percent and the
sort of latency is around you know 11
seconds
um running on on my device
and so you know this is kind of kind of
nice like you know 82 accuracy on this
data set with um you know just eight
level examples per class uh it's quite
good
um and so at this point right you might
say okay I'm done I can just deploy this
and you know call it a day but you know
the thing that you typically ask
yourself is like okay could I use a
smaller model to get similar performance
so what we're going to do next is we're
going to now take a different sentence
Transformer this is the mini LM
Transformer that Oren was mentioning
and this is going to be it's around four
times uh smaller or even more seven
times smaller than the original model
um we're going to train it in the exact
same way and then we're going to compute
the metrics and we just get a sense of
like you know how much the performance
is impacted
um by using the smaller model
and so as you can see it's 66 megabytes
uh the performance has dropped almost
you know five seven percent sorry
um and the latency has also gone down
which is good so we've got something
that is faster but it's got you know a
big hit in inaccuracy
and we can actually visualize that using
this function here where we can see that
you know
um the original sort of mpnet model has
a latency of around 11 seconds and an
accuracy of 82 but the sort of student
model
um has you know much faster latency but
has it suffered this performance hit
and so the kind of thing we want to show
now is that if we use knowledge
distillation to essentially train the
same mini LM model but if we combine it
with the kind of embeddings from the
teacher we can ultimately end up with
something which is um you know hopefully
as performant
um so there's a question here which is
kind of maybe relevant for what we're
about to do which is
um you know in this case I'm just using
unlabeled data which is kind of of the
same domain so to speak
um what happens if we had just
completely random you know text news
and yeah that's kind of interesting
question Aaron I I guess do you have any
sort of experience here like if we took
you know the sort of 16 labeled examples
or whatever for the teacher
to train on Aging news and then we had
just random news articles
do you think the distillation would also
work or is it important that it kind of
has the same kind of distribution to
start off with
I think that the the same distribution
helps here
um
yeah and do you mean from take data from
completely different domains here
yeah I think I think what Muhammad's
asking is yeah like if we maybe just had
news articles from like you know a
different place you know maybe we have a
bunch of news articles from Reuters and
then I don't know maybe the news
articles are from BBC or something or
you know Reddit or whatever
yeah I think it depends on the semantic
relatedness right in the in the Lego
data
yeah but it's definitely interesting to
to test
yeah I guess the main thing I'll say
that Muhammad is that um you'll see in a
second this is quite fast to to
experiment with so you can always just
run the experiments very quickly and
check for yourself
um and there's a question from ankush
about will this notebook be available
um yeah it's available already so if you
go to Hanging face workshops
you click on the future learning in
production
folder in the set feed optimization you
can already run it
okay so this is like a starting point we
want to make this mini Ln model better
in accuracy and so now we're going to
use a distillation
set for trainer which again we load now
same mini LM model but what we're going
to do is we're going to feed into this
distillation trainer the teacher model
we're going to feed the student and
we're also going to provide this
unlabeled data
for the trainer to to work on this kind
of you know semantic embedding
comparison
and so if we run this it's um you know
very similar code to what we saw before
training the
um the standard set bit models but now
it takes um you know a little bit longer
because now we're kind of you know doing
this kind of unlabeled data comparison
of the embeddings between the student
and the teacher but nevertheless this is
only going to take roughly you know a
minute
on my GPU you know using these 1000
unlabeled examples and so you know if
you had more unlabeled data it's roughly
going to scale linearly so again these
are things that kind of show that you
know even though you're using like a lot
more data to train the model
um you're not paying like a very heavy
penalty
um whereas you know some of the other
sort of techniques that people use for
like few short learning and distillation
they often use like generative models
like you know gpt2 which have to like do
a lot of heavy lifting
um to kind of do this um kind of
compression step
so this should run in around another 10
seconds
and then we should see what happens when
we get to the end of this plot
so there's a question here whilst
running oh no
um
can we use distillation for semantic
search I think the answer is yes you can
do it for getting good embeddings and
you know if you have more questions you
can open an issue on the set food repo
um but what we see here is now we've got
a model which is the mini LM model of 66
Meg but it's now basically got the 82
accuracy that we started with from the
teacher but has the benefit now of being
you know roughly three times faster
so this is this is quite cool right
we're seeing that we can shrink the
model significantly in latency but we
get a significant boost over just
training
um the student model on the um kind of
you know few labeled examples we have
so
um here I'm going to now push this model
to the hub and so if we run this um push
to HUB cell it will basically push a
model to the hub which contains
um a bunch of files so you'll have all
the things that you need to basically
you know deploy it run inference with it
and what I want to show you now is like
at this stage you know you could deploy
this on your own kind of infrastructure
whatever you want but I want to show you
a kind of nice technique
um of how we can deploy this on on
inference endpoints
so inference endpoints is a service that
high in Phase offers to kind of deploy
your models on the Hub on like a fully
managed kind of cloud infrastructure but
it also has the advantage that you can
do this in a secure way so you don't you
know have to worry about you know all
the kind of issues of like you know
having like hosted models on some
external thing you can really run this
you know privately through your own
cloud
and so to give you a sense of like what
it takes to deploy a model
um the way this works is you basically
provide
um the repository that you're dealing
with so here I've got a set fit model
and it's the mini LM let's build one
and then you can select the cloud
provider that you want to deploy on and
so at the moment we support AWS and
azure
and so I'm just going to pick AWS uh
because you know why not and I'm going
to pick Ireland because I'm in
Switzerland so let's make it close to
where I live
and here you can select a few of like
the sort of different Hardware that is
available you know in this region for
this cloud provider
and since we've now got this like you
know relatively small model I can
actually pick essentially the smallest
available CPU which is one of these
Intel isolate CPUs with 2gig of RAM
and then I'm going to just specify a few
things if I want to about the advanced
configuration this is a task which is
actually for text classification so
let's do it here
I can also specify things like Auto
scaling and stuff like that but um you
know for that I think we can we can
leave that out and I can also change the
framework if I want but this is
automatically detected that this was a
pytorch model
and then you know at the very end you
can also specify whether you want this
to be like fully private using you know
something like these private link
connections that cloud providers have
but since this model has been trained on
you know public data I'm just going to
make it public and so when I hit create
endpoint
this will
now essentially start building a
container
and then once that container is deployed
and built we can then actually you know
query this and you know use it in
applications Downstream
so building the container takes a few
minutes so while that's happening I'll
just show you one
that I built earlier
so here's one that I deployed earlier
and now we've got something that is
running and we can now provide examples
just to test it out so we can say like
okay
um in you know in today's
news Morocco
trashed
front in the World Cup
I guess we'll see
and that has identified it you know
indeed it's about Sport and you know we
can think of other things like Okay
um like I don't know
um Intel releases
um the biggest language model on CPUs or
something then drinks Frost is in
everything so you kind of get a sense
that you know the model is is is
moderately good at you know classifying
these kind of um you know simple things
um and then you know when this is
deployed you can also use
um you know curl to run this so if I
have you know my
and
um uh you know I want to put this in
like a request thing I can then feed
that into my terminal and now you know
I've fed in this text and now I've got
uh the label the score and so on so this
kind of shows you in a space of a couple
of minutes how you can take you know a
model that's already on the Hub and then
you can deploy it on your own kind of
selection of hardware
and that's
um you know one thing that I find quite
nice because a lot of the time you know
you know if you you might want to
experiment as a developer and say okay
maybe it's better that I use a GPU for
this type of thing or a CPU and when
you're dealing a lot with like external
you know inference providers you don't
quite have that flexibility
now the one caveat here I want to
mention is that
um inference endpoints supports
um several Frameworks out of the box so
it supports Transformers out of the box
but set fit is kind of uh you know its
own library right so it's not something
that is natively supported in inference
endpoints
so what I actually did to make this work
is I implemented something called a
custom Handler
and this customer Handler is essentially
a class that just tells inference
endpoints you know what is the the
forward pass given a payload what is the
output
and so here this endpoint Handler just
basically loads my separate model it
defines the label mapping and then in
the forward pass I receive some payload
and then I just feed that payload
through the model and then return an
array of of you know the labels so this
again is is something that is quite neat
because you can basically write like you
can deploy arbitrary models I can deploy
you know random pytorch models I can
deploy random tensorflow models and as
long as I sort of implement this kind of
endpoint Handler I'm able to kind of
control specifically you know how how
the inference is done
which is another kind of nice part of
flexibility that you don't quite get
with you know external API providers
okay so that's a super uh quick example
of inference endpoints
um I'll take some questions later if
there are any
um but now that we've seen you know how
to do installation I want to just wrap
up by diving into like this like last
kind of thing can we squeeze even more
performance out of this to a model
so the way we're going to do this with
the internal neural compressor is the
neural compressor can apply quantization
um on different sort of Frameworks so
you can do compre basically quantization
on
um sort of like the the native pytorch
model
um or tensorflow but it turns out that
if you want to get kind of like the best
kind of compression
um it's good if we kind of take an
intermediate step where we convert the
model to Onyx and then we're going to
compress the Onyx model and that's the
thing that we'll then run
so the way that um we can convert the
model to Onyx is we're going to use
something called Optimum which is a
library we have at hugging face for
basically wrapping all of these Onyx
models and running them through Onyx
runtime
and so now I'm going to load the model
that we've trained
using what's called a feature extraction
model so this is basically just the body
of the um of the of the model this is
like the center Transformer
and then I'm just going to save this to
disk so that now we've got something
called let's see we've got the tokenizer
and we also should have
now in this folder
an onyx model
so I'm not going to go into tons of
details about you know what Onyx is but
you can just think of it as a way of
kind of capturing
um your you know the structure of it or
the architecture of your model in terms
of a graph where all the nodes in the
graph uh represent operators so you
might have nodes where you've got things
for like you know matrix multiplication
you'll have nodes for like the
activations and so on and once you've
got that graph you can then do tricks
like you can combine nodes you can kind
of apply quantization and that's what
we're going to use with Intel neural
compressor
so because we have an onyx model now
it's not like Pi torch where we can just
you know run it using like pytorch
modules what we actually need to do is
create
um a kind of Onyx version of the settfit
model that we used previously in all the
training
and so this is like it looks a little
bit complicated but it's not too much we
just have to implement something which
takes an onyx model takes the tokenizer
and the model head that we trained from
the student
and then we just Implement a predict
function which is going to basically
Define how do we do inference with Onyx
in Linux runtime and then we have a call
method which will then you know just
essentially wrap that predict method
and so now if we instantiate one of
these Onyx models we can basically feed
in some text examples so here you can
see here we've got a couple of examples
from the test set and then this will now
generate you know predicted labels
um identical or very similar to you know
the original pytosh model that we had
so we've got now an onyx version of our
set fit model let's now you know
quantize this model
so the way this works in Intel neural
compressor is we have to define a few
couple of pieces so the first thing we
need to Define is essentially an
evaluation function which basically will
compute the accuracy of the model at a
given step in this tuning regime so
basically the neural compressor will try
to figure out which kind of parts of
this Onyx graph should be quantized you
know to get the best kind of accuracy
and this evaluation function is just
simply going to take in the model at
some point compute the predictions and
then finally return the accuracy
so the details here are maybe not super
exciting and interesting but basically
we're just Computing accuracy from the
Onyx model
and so I'll Define that
the other thing we need to Define is
essentially a yaml file which specifies
um kind of what framework we want to use
for quantization so here we're using
um you know Onyx runtime we're using CPU
for for inference and we're specifying
that this is now Dynamic quantization
sort of post training
and we set some threshold on like okay
when should I terminate the tuning and
my kind of criteria is that you know I
basically don't want my accuracy to drop
more than you know 0.01 relative to my
Baseline
so we're going to save that in the CML
file
and now the last step is to basically
Define this quantization object from the
neural compressor
and this quantization object will now be
essentially the thing that will run the
tuning so here I'm basically feeding the
Onyx model I'm feeding this evaluation
function and now I'm going to run the
quantizer
and what this is doing is this is
basically running this evaluation
function to get a measure of the
accuracy
applying some quantization to the Onyx
graph and then running the valuation
again and it does this several times so
that
um you know at the end you say okay this
was the best kind of set of uh you know
quantized operations I can find
so this takes like around a minute or so
to run so while it's going I'll think if
there are some questions
so
yeah so here's a question from Javier
about inference endpoints so is it
planned or available a paid by use plan
for endpoints currently you only pay by
hour
that's a great question as far as I know
there are discussions of kind of
thinking about you know what might
something like serverless work look like
for inference endpoints but if you want
to know specifically I recommend just um
getting in touch with Philip Schmidt or
just seeing an email to hugging face and
they'll be able to answer that
um let's see another question
what amount of
per class samples would be needed for
100 plus classes
yeah that's a great question so
I think in the extreme you know label
classification context
um what we've seen is that
um the problem here is typically you'll
have like a lot of sparsity so you'll
have you know some of the the classes
are like densely populated but then
you'll have some very rare ones
and I don't have like a kind of you know
golden rule of thumb for what that
should be
um but some experiments people have done
the community show that you know if you
if you even if you're only able to have
around eight to ten labeled examples
across these classes you can get like a
very strong
um Baseline so maybe you're not
something that you can you know use in
production but at least it's something
that you can you know build from
okay so this is now run the Intel neural
compressor and you can see that it says
okay we started off with a baseline in
the full Precision model of 82 percent
and then at the end we found the the
best kind of compressed model
um is you know 81.9 percent
um and now we've got something which has
been kind of quantized into this 8-bit
integer precision and so what I'm going
to do now is I'm going to save that to
disk as model quantos to Onyx
and now what I'm going to do to just
wrap things up is basically run the
performance Benchmark but now I need to
just Define how do I compute the size of
the model because previously I was using
pytorch to do that so here I have to
actually just look at the the size of
the model on disk and then to compute
the accuracy I now need to use a
slightly different logic because in the
pytorch case we were able to use the the
pytorch trainer
but these again are just some details
you can look at after this Workshop
so I'm going to basically load first the
Onyx model and then I'm going to feed it
into my Onyx septic model
and now we're going to run this
inference benchmark
and so what you can see here is that
this is now compressed the model from 66
megabytes which was the distilled
version into 17 megabytes which is quite
impressive that's like a factor of you
know three and a half
and for a lot of like quantization
techniques typically you'll only see
like a 2X compression natively but
because the Intel neural compressor does
this kind of tuning directly on the Onyx
graph it's able to get like a very
efficient representation
and so
we'll soon see what the effect is on
um before on on accuracy and on the
latency let's give it a second
so the accuracy indeed has only gone
down to 81.9 and here you can see the um
the latency is quite impressive this is
now
um hitting you know the one millisecond
latency range and we've now been able to
you know relative to where we started
from right we started off here with this
mpnet model and by adding distillation
and quantization you go roughly from you
know 11 milliseconds down to roughly one
so that's like a factor of 10 reduction
um you know in your latency
so when I saw this I was like well this
is cool because usually I'm only used to
seeing like 2x games and Intel neural
compressor is quite impressive in this
respect
so maybe the the last thing to mention
is like you know why do all this stuff
like we've been talking about like you
know optimizing for you know latency and
throughput and stuff but um a kind of
like bottom line comparison to show you
what I'm talking about is
um you know if you take the state of the
art for future learning today
um which is the tfue model
um if you want to deploy this
um into production you're going to need
to use for example an inference endpoint
which is an a100 with 80 gigabytes of
GPU memory and so the hourly rate for
this is around six and a half dollars
um but by comparison
we can deploy this compressed Fitbit
model on you know the very smaller CPU
that we found which was you know this
one vcpu with two gigabytes of RAM and
so you can see it's almost it's over
actually over 100x reduction in price
and I think that's like you know if
you're working in Industry these are the
things that I sort of you know are
important to take away where you know if
you only read Twitter and stuff you
might get the impression that like you
know large language models have like
taking over the world
but there's a kind of deeper story here
which is like if you actually want to
use them in your in your job
um the cost of deploying them is an
important consideration and um you know
what I hope we've shown you today is
that a technique like set fit
um for the specific use case of text
classification which happens to be you
know one of the most common ones
um is a way to both iterate very fast in
your development because you saw that we
could train all these models um in
seconds
um but then for the deployment you're
able to you know significantly reduce
costs
so that kind of wraps up
um what we wanted to show you today we
covered a huge amount of stuff so I'm
pretty sure like you know your your mind
is uh exploding and it's time to now you
know watch some football but um if you
want to again dive into the details you
can check out the the workshops wrapper
on GitHub and then the setfield
optimization notebook
and maybe what we can do now is take a
few questions from the chat
so
the first question is is tfue also
quantize in this comparison no so that's
a good that's a good point um in this
comparison I'm just comparing
um just a few unquantized
um
probably one could maybe you know apply
some techniques like distillation and
quantization
[Music]
um and then you would you know the
relative comparison would be lower but
generally speaking
um you know just doing you know training
and stuff all those things with large
models requires more Hardware so you
need like you know to factor in those
kind of additional costs
foreign
[Music]
so let's see
what kind of questions do we have
yeah so another question is um from
Javier is like is the model head a pie
torch in a module
so
um in the examples I showed today it's
actually simpler than that it's just a
set fit logistic regressor but in the
set fit Library itself we do provide an
implementation that's pure pie torch so
if you if you want to just stay you know
fully in the potush realm you can do
that and that works you know just as
well
and
let's see what other questions we have
here
oh yeah so there was a question from
amra about the latency numbers
um so the the ones that I showed at the
end with the quantize model were on CPU
um the ones previously were actually on
on GPU um but I did a comparison
internally just to see you know what the
difference was and it was kind of
negligible for this particular example
so all of these plots that I showed here
um they they basically look identical if
we run everything on CPU
um
just just checking through the questions
yeah maybe this is a question for like
Moshi Oren so
um you know could you like pre-compute
embeddings for set fit uh for inference
so you know maybe you've got a database
of documents and you want to classify
the text based on sort of a question
appends to the docs
um I guess the answer is yes but I'm
just curious you know what do you think
what do you think
um
I'll try to understand the questions but
uh
thank you
I I think the way we can think about it
is like um you know
in some cases I think when people are
doing things like you know semantic
search they often like pre-compute
embeddings and then store them on like
an index
um that lets you do like Fast lookup
like Vice or something yeah and I guess
the question here is asking you know
would a similar technique help the set
fit my kind of hunch is like one could
do that but probably it doesn't bring
you much gain because you know the model
is so fast that
um you don't really need to do any of
this like pre-computing I think if it's
related to semantic search I think you
can apply the same methods also for
semantic search and and actually benefit
from distillation the same way that we
show for text classification so I think
it would be interesting to validate on
semantic search tasks I think this it
should work the same you can you can do
it in offline you can you can have a
smaller
um sentence Transformer model and apply
it as a for semantic search
yeah I think this is um
a nice approach to optimize semantic
search in production basically not not
just text specifications
yeah sure totally agree yeah
um
and then there's
um let's see if I'm looking through the
comments
so I would just mention that uh what you
see here in the graph are the the
smaller smaller is 25x smaller than the
teacher and you see it's comparable
performance so in terms of not just
latency but also model size is 25x
compared to the teacher
so yeah it's quite efficient for
production
Okay so
here's an interesting one just to wrap
up the the session is um sort of like
you know could you have like a human in
the loop
um
kind of combination so you're using set
fit to kind of bootstrap your your your
labeling and then you know as you
collect more labels you can then sort of
update the model
um my understanding is that this is
possible there's a library called argea
which is a kind of labeling tool and I
think as far as I know they have a nice
tutorial where they use set fit to kind
of do this like active learning process
um but indeed I think Moshi and Aaron
you've also done experiments using like
set fit to generate like pseudo labels
right like where you you train on a
small number of of examples and then you
can kind of generate kind of like weak
labels
um or maybe I'm misremembering the
experiments
yeah maybe something that is related
what I did is uh first uh have a few
shots with eight samples and create a
new model and then use this model in a
thunder way to to get more data to
continue to do future planning so it's
possible you know to have kind of uh
few steps
that you in each step you create a new
uh fine-tune model and then use this
model for the next step with more data
so really possible and it's actually
can boost your performance
you can add more data if you and start
with a fine tune model already yeah
so it's it's a good approach
definitely
yeah another Point could be
self-supervised learning right when when
you start off with those eight table
samples per class and then classify and
label data and then choose the best data
and retrain the model
iteratively
yeah that's something that we're also
into and we want to examine
Okay cool so I think with that
um let's call the deny I want to thank
everyone for for joining
um I'll um I'll very quickly put a link
in the chat
um
to the notebooks
so for everyone who wants to run this uh
you know during the match
um but yeah again thank you very much to
everyone for joining and for the very
interesting questions uh the recording
um will be available on YouTube
um shortly after the session
um and um you know if if you don't see
it you can always just get in touch with
uh with me
um I'm pretty easy to find there's only
one Lewis Tunstall in the world I think
and if you find me you'll find me on
Twitter
so yeah thanks again and uh have a good
evening
bye